off we go with the short okay so I had
to take my seven eight year old Chinese
mom
to her gynecologist checkup appointment
and I had a trick is a already my hopes
for this story are so high I tell you
sure so basically we get to the office I
tell her gynecologist that I have to
translate a gynecologist has a smirk on
her face and says well I'm gonna have to
ask you a couple uncomfortable questions
um you know translate for your mom so
she's like I need to know if your mom is
sexually active I need to know how
active she is so keep in mind she's 70
years old so I am translated in Chinese
I'm like Mamma Mia about what Juliet ma
basically that means do you guys still
have sucks so my mom hits me in the
shoulder she's like you know your dad of
course we do five to six times a week
like I am completely embarrassed my
mom's not even shy about it
I go from like basically embarrassed to
depressed it's getting more than I am
getting off easy where you
that's why said his mother cat
they'll cut that out
I think I'm more naturally a horse than
the horse what hello okay hello ha cuz
that's what you say it's not
Aloha well Aloha Aloha